[Music]
what is complementarity the only look as
you probably all see I'm not the most
structured thinker right I'm an
associative thinker this did you notice
right so I am clear that I need an
editor I or an organiser or a structured
person or somebody who says stop you
know that and I can only continue do
what I do because I have somebody else
who is doing that which I don't the
complementarity is the app is the
compact the possibility for each person
to be who they are
so complementarity is your partner
allowing you to be who you are at your
best without having to try to do that
which you can learn but it will never be
your second nature and I think that when
you hire new people you hire along this
complementarity thing and it's it's the
it's not just that the parts make the
hole but that the hole cannot exist
without the parts it can't exist it can
survive it can hobble along it can you
know because you need to in the
beginning but at some point you really
need the various the various pieces a
family has parents spouses children
friends grandparents schools it's an
entire ecology everybody understands
that
collective thinking it's the same in a
company it sounds like you're suggesting
we should be screening for some very
candid sense of self I mean it's
important that people really do be able
to acknowledge their fault and also be
able to kind of communicate them in
order for this balance of
complementarities to work yes yes but I
would go a step further it's not just
that you have to acknowledge fold I
think you know if I said that trust is
probably the number one I think the
number two of any relational system is
the ability to take responsibility for
your contribution to the pie the good
and the bad and generally people confuse
responsibility with blame or self blame
rather than that's it they are
did you own myself as a flawed person
and still hold myself in high regard I
up I messed up I should have done
this I wished I had thought of that it's
extremely liberating to actually not try
to be perfect
so what is the definition of self-esteem
it's the ability to see yourself as a
flawed individual and still hold
yourself in high regard
flaw is the key word you had it in a
previous sentence once you can say I
don't know rather than pretending or
hoping or to actually take
responsibility to come to the other
person or to the team for that matter
and to just say I didn't I didn't do
this
and it's an amazing thing when you come
to me and you say I up generally
I don't say yeah that's true I just say
that's okay we'll figure it out the
minute the other person takes this was
really for something you you know you're
not branding your flag and you know as
you generally just say huh
I mean now what shall we do we have a
problem but it is it's an amazing thing
in any relational system when people
take ownership ownership is another word
there is something incredibly relieving
when the person you're working with
somebody that regardless of how much
they may error make an error of judgment
or a mistake in any given instant that
regardless you're not going to question
their intentions and once that becomes
resolved it just lets so much pressure
out of the system and those you know the
issues you were describing of finding
flaws in their strengths and turning you
know and and and becoming nitpicky that
actually I think dissipates you know and
once you cross that threshold to that
you know really fundamental trust it
just opens up a lot of potential by by
dialing down a lot of the you know of
the you know little problems that pop up
the you versus weed distinction sort of
you've got to have your mindset framed
around we're in this together we're on
the same team and as long as you are
pointing fingers it leads to these sorts
of unraveling
or you think like this every
relationship has three components you me
us and the US actually encompasses me so
if I'm going to do something one of the
best screeners is if I do this now if I
say this now what will this do to us
even though I may be totally right but
I'm not sure it will do good to us and
if it doesn't do good to us it doesn't
do good to me that's the that's the real
frame of thinking relationally
relational thinking is not I think about
me I think about you is I think about
myself as part of something of which
both of us are part of and that can
appear above us if you want is what I'm
trying to protect
[Music]